what is going through your head right
now what is this moment like yeah it's
pretty surreal i mean it's particularly
surreal because it's
uh what time is it three it's like 3 30
a.m
in the uk so um and i've been drinking
coffee all night so i'm
sort of peak buzz right now um
but mostly it just means honestly i kind
of
um really it's one of the most
incredible moments i mean obviously it's
the most incredible moment of my career
and
um you really i really kind of never
dreamt that i'd be
in this position and so um it means the
world and particularly in this
kind of difficult time it just it's
great to have been
recognized and for the whole show to
have been recognized um
yeah so i'm very grateful basically
where are you right now and are you
somewhere where you can celebrate a
little bit or do you have to keep it
down
i am in a hotel room
on my own and i have a little bit of
champagne
but to be honest i'm sort of like i'm
trying to work out how best to fall
asleep after these press course
i don't think i'll be able to because
i'm so excited and i've been having a
little party on my own so um
yeah but uh but it's it's in a hotel in
central london so
it's very strange wow hey um prince
harry admitted that he watches the crown
what do you think of that
oh i mean i i had no idea about that no
i'm delighted i'm delighted that he
watches it i think um
you know anyone who watches it is is a
great is great you know
that's what we that's what we do it for
it has been a big night for the show
that i mean emma wins jillian wins
how does that feel and what does that
say about the work you guys did
um yeah i mean it's it's uh it's really
special i think
you know particularly emma because emma
and i went on this journey together and
um although the relationship in the
series is torrid we're actually very
good
friends and um you know like it
the only thing that topped me winning
tonight was seeing emma win and
and all the hard work she put in and i
put in and
and olivia and tobias and you know
the other thing that's always it's so
difficult with these things because
you know it's easy to forget all the
other brilliant actors but also the
other crew and
tonight i just think about aaron dirty
and tobias menzies and helena carter and
you know and then the crew olivia you
know olivia but also the directors
and the cinematographers and the set
designers and the costume makers and the
runners you know
it's a huge operation and this award all
of these awards
wouldn't be possible without them really
in america there is a massive appetite
for the royal family just like
in the uk what is it like walking around
now
after playing charles um
it's pretty normal to be honest it's
pretty um
yeah i mean i don't get recognized that
much and i don't know if that's because
i normally wear hoodies and t-shirts and
jeans and trainers but uh
i mean i had a recent kind of strange
interaction with a neighbor who um
who i walked past on the way to the
local shop
who bowed down and said your royal
highness like that was pretty weird
um so that was the kind of moment of
like this is
surreal but apart from that it's um it's
pretty much the same
actually it's i'm really fortunate my
life hasn't changed
all that much so yeah now that you've
won the golden globe if you could have a
conversation with charles
what would you say to him oh gosh um
it's funny because i feel so um departed
from the real person it's like the
character's got its own life and
although it's based in on this real
person it feels so far removed from that
um i think you know through my research
i've grown
to you know really fond of him and i
suspect uh
my the main thing would be just to say
you know
how impressed i am with all the work
he's done for the environment and for
charities and
that'll be the main thing i think it's
3am there but your friends are blowing
you up huh
well you say that most of them are in
bed
mom and dad are in bed my brothers are
in bed
so i've had my girlfriend called me
because she lives in new york so i got a
phone call from her
and uh and olivia coleman just said just
facetimed me and she was going wild so
that was nice
and emma corin obviously so all the
crown are going wild and i think
probably i'll get lots of calls in the
morning
uh when i'll be in bed sleeping so yeah
prince harry suggested that you cast
damian lewis to play him he was joking
but maybe he wasn't joking
damien lewis what do you think of that
oh i love damien lewis he's great
so you know i think the great thing
about the crown is that we um
we we put together great casts and so
i'm so
excited the next season and everyone
who's involved in that and i'm sure that
if it comes to damien lewis i think
that'd be a pretty good pretty good bit
of casting be great
all right also is um will you be back or
is
we're hearing dominic west might take
over oh yeah i don't know if that's
i'm definitely not going to be back
unfortunately but um whether dominic's
taking over
i i've heard the same but i don't know
if that's true or not i'm very out of
touch so
if dominic does it i know dominic and
he's brilliant and he'll be
terrific um uh whoever does it will be
brilliant but um any advice for the next
person
any advice about well look if it's
dominic west then i don't think i could
give him
any advice it would be pretty rich of me
to give him advice so
um yeah look they'll do they'll make the
right decision whoever it is and if it's
dominic it will be magic
i'm sure josh congratulations you were
fantastic in this role
you deserve that golden globe enjoy it
and uh
have a couple more sips of champagne i
know it's late you know i'm gonna go
have some more champagne i'm not gonna
go to bed i'll do it thank you very much
thank you thanks all right take care bye
you